[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامج من
المصدر المهتم بتحليل المشهد الاعلامي
العربي والدولي ثلاثه مواضيع استوقفتنا
هذا الاسبوع
الهجوم المثير والمفاجاه على ايران يخطف
الانظار الاعلام الدوليه يضع الضربه في
سياق حرب اوكرانيا وروسيا تحذر نحاول ناشر
تفاصيل الهجوم الذي يحمل بصمات اسرائيليه
امريكيه في وسط جيرل
غداء سري لاعلاميين مع ماكرون يكشف ويعمق
ازمه الثقه بالرئيس الفرنسي الذي يواجه
احتجاجات عارمه ضد سياساته فاللقاء الرئيس
مع الصحفيين تدخل سلطه في الاعلام عن
الضجه حول الموضوع شعبويه صحفيه
جدالا واسعا بلغ مستوى دبلوماسي كيف تسللت
الصحوه اليسريه الى الاعلام وهل حل النضال
الايديولوجي محل المهنيه والحياد
[موسيقى]
الدولي وليس فقط الاعلام في منطقتنا انشغل
بخبر درب منشات ايران العسكريه في اطار
عمليه تحمل بصمات امريكيه اسرائيليه وافقى
عنوان لمقال الكاتب البارز عبد الرحمن
الراشد فان استهداف ايران المثير والمفاجئ
جاءك رد واضح على المشاركه للدرونز
الايرانيه لحرب اوكرانيا لتصبح ايران ضمن
دائره اهداف الحرب في اوكرانيا وينتقل
الصراع الروسي الغربي الى منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
وعليه دخل الاعلام الروسي والاوكراني على
خط التغطيه المكثفه للحدث لنقل الضغط
تفاصيل الهجوم على مصانع الذخيره
والمسيرات في ايران لما لها انعكاسات على
تطورات الاحداث العسكريه في اوكرانيا في
اوكرانيا افردت القنوات والصحف تحليلات
حول تاثير هذا الهجوم على عمليات تزويد
ايران روسيا بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ
الباستيه التي يعتقد ان ايران ستمدها بها
ناقشت مع السفير الاسرائيلي السابق في
موسكو تداعيات الضرب على الحرب في
اوكرانيا وجاء في الصحيفه ثناء على جهود
ضرب ايران التي تقود الاستقرار العالمي
وعلى مواقع التواصل بدات تحليل واضحا في
تعليقات الاوكرانيين من ضمنهم مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني ميخالو
الذي سارع بالقول في تغريده ليلى متفجره
في ايران اثرت على انتاج المسيرات
والصواريخ ومصاف النفط ان اوكرانيا حذرتكم
واشار الى منطق الحرب يجعل المرتكبين
والمتواطئين يدفعون الثمن
ايران التي احتجت على كييف باستدعاء
القائم بالاعمال الاوكرانيه حاولت التخفيف
من وطئه الهجوم الذي اخترق دفاعاتها
بسهوله وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه قالت في
بيان رسمي ان الهجوم نفذته ثلاث مسيرات
صغيره الحجم من نوع كود كابتر تصدت لها
الدفاعات الايرانيه فيما صور التي نشرتها
المعارضه تظهر عكس ذلك
دائما تتعرض للهجوم وتتظاهر ايران في
البدايه ان الهجمات فشلت ولا تعترف
بخسائرها الا بعد انتشار صور الاقمار
الصناعيه او غيرها من الادله في الفضاء
الالكتروني هذا ما جرى في تفجير مصنع
اصفهان فالتلفزيون الرسمي السابع الى موقع
الحدث لبست روايته عن الموضوع ونشر الصور
عن مكوناتي وهيكل للنظام التشغيل المسيرات
التي زعمت انها اسقطت بفعل متانه الدفاعات
الجويه في المنطقه المقتظه بمعامل تصنيع
الاسلحه في حين ان الاعلام الرسمي نفسه
قال ان المسيرات التي استخدمت بالهجوم
مصممه لتسقط على الهدف وتفجره بما تحمله
من شحنه متفجره
هذا ووصف معهد اتلانتك الهجوم بالمحرج
بالنسبه الى ايران ويظهر مره اخرى ضعف
القوام العسكري الايراني الذي لا يستقوي
الا على المتظاهرين العسل
دخلت روسيا على خط الهجوم في اصفهان وحذرت
مما وصفتها بالتصرفات الاستفزازيه التي
تثير تصعيدا في وضع ملتهب اصلا رئيسه
قنوات روسيا اليوم الاعلاميه الابرز في
روسيا
رددت ما قالته الخارجيه الروسيه عن مغبه
تبعات دخول اطراف اخرى على الحرب في
اوكرانيا وحددت من ان هذا التصعيد من شانه
ان يؤدي الى حرب العالميه ثالثه
في الاثناء كان الاعلام الروسي يلمح الى
ان قصف الامريكيين لمواقع ايرانيه هدفه
التعمي على المفاوضات السرديه الامريكيه
مع ايران وهو خبر لم تنم فيه السلطات
الامريكيه لدى سؤال الخريجيه عن الموضوع
حيث اجاب الناطق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
قائلا على الرغم من ان الاتفاق النووي ليس
على جدول الاعمال فان لدينا الوسائل
لايصال الرسائل المحدده وحازمه الى ايران
عندما يكون من مصلحه امريكا القيام بذلك
هذا في وقت لا يزال المبعوث الامريكي يامل
ببلوغ اتفاق النووي وقد كشفت صحفته واشنطن
ان هناك جماعات ضغط داخل واشنطن تعمل على
اعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي من خلال
مجموعه مشرعين في مجلس النواب والكونغرس
تطالب الرئيس بايدن بابقاء قنوات الحوار
مفتوحه
اللافت انه مع بروز خبر ضربه اصفهان
التزمت من ناحيتها اسرائيل الصمت فاحجم
متحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي عن التعليق
باستثناء ماء وردته صحيفه الجرز عن مصادر
المخابرات الغربيه بان الهجوم حقق نجاحا
هائلا على الرغم من المزاعم الايرانيه هذا
فيما رفض المسؤولون الاسرائيليون التعليق
على الخبر الذي كانت قد فجرته
اقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين واشخاص مطلعين
عنوان الصحيفه اسرائيل تضرب ايران وسط
مساعي دوليه لاحتواء طهران راب القنوات
العالميه وذلك قبل ان تؤكد وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه ذلك باصدارها بيانا رسميا حول
الانفجار في تطور قال مسؤولون امريكيون
ومصادر مطلعه لصحيفه انه اتى بعد زياره
سريه لرئيس السي اي اي في وقت تبحث
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل عن طرق جديده
لاحتواء طموحات طهران نوويه والعسكريه
من اوائل الوسائل الاعلاميه طبعا من ضمنهم
العربيه كانت قد اكدت ان اسرائيل تقف وراء
الضرب على ايران ضمن استراتيجيه امريكا
الجديده لاحتواء النظام الايراني وينضموا
الينا من واشنطن كاتب المقال جوردن هل
كانت مصادرك في الاساس من اسرائيل من
الولايات المتحده علما ان واشنطن نفت علنا
اي تورط في الامر
لا استطيع تحديد مصادرنا ولكن ما استطيع
ان اؤكده انه جهد قام على الاستفسار من
مصادر عده
لمقارنتها للتاكد من الخبر قبل نشره تقرير
ده اشار الى ان العمليه تمت بنجاح حيث
انها حققت اهدافها بالكامل دائما ما ستكون
هناك سرديه مختلفه للاحداث من الطرف الاخر
في السر والعلن ولكن معلوماتنا تؤكد ان
العمليه كادت ناجحه وحققت ما كانت تسعى
اليه بحسب معلوماتك هل تجزم ان اداره
بايدن غيرت استراتيجيتها فيما يتعلق
باحتواء ايران
الولايات المتحده بدات تبحث عن مقاربه
مختلفه لاحتوائي ايران احتمال العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي الضعيف نوعا ما في
المستقبل القريب نرى ان موقف واشنطن تغير
منذ استلام بيض السلطه لكن الولايات
المتحده منشغله حاليا بالملف الاوكراني
وغيره من الملفات لم تقر صراحه بان
حليفتها في هذه الحال اسرائيل هي من قامت
بالمهمه وهذا تصرف المعهود من اداره بايدن
بعدم الزج بنفسها في الصراعات بشكل مباشر
هذا الهجوم نفذ بعد ايام من تدريبات
عسكريه المشتركه بين اسرائيل و واشنطن
قرابه 650 عنصرا امريكيا شاركوا في هذه
المناورات في محاكاه للتهديدات الايرانيه
كان تعاونا اعمق من اي وقت مضى بين
البلدين في الفتره الاخيره في اطار التصدي
لايران وفق معلومات متوافره هل تع
تقد ان انتقل انطلقت من داخل ايران وفق ما
قيل
هلعرفه ان هذه الطائرات التي نفذت الهجوم
ليست بعيده المدى بالتالي احتمال كبير ان
تكون اطلقت من داخل ايران الكاتب الصحفي
في ورشه جونل جوردن لوبول شكرا جزيلا لك
اسي ان تستعين بالمقدمه الكوميدي لتقديمه
فقره فكاهيه على المحطه الاخباريه في مسعى
على ما يبدو لتحسين نسب مشاهديها فهل ينجح
في مهمته بعض الفاصل نتعرف اكثر عن
الموضوع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في فرنسا المشتعله على
وقع التظاهرات ضد السياسات ماكرون
الاقتصاديه يتلقى اعلامها سهام الانتقادات
ايضا وذلك بعد غداء سري جمع بين ممثلين عن
اهم وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه مع رئيس
الفرنسي في قصر الاليزياء في فرنسا وذلك
عشيه اندلاع المظاهرات الاولى فهل تحول
الاعلام الفرنسي الى اعلام سلطه في عهد
مكروم بمجرد اجتماعه بقاده الراي من دون
ذكر ذلك علنا هذا ما يعتقده المعارضون
الذين يرون ان هدف مكروه من ذلك الغداء
تلقين الشخصيات الاعلاميه خطابه لتسويقه
محليا بغيه التاثير على الراي العام بشكل
غير مباشر وقلبه لصالح الرئيس وقراراته
فيما يخص الوضع الاجتماعي
لنتابع ابرز ما جاء من انتقادات في
الاعلام الفرنسي بعدما كشف عن الغداء
السري الذي جمع بين الرئيس الفرنسي
والممثلين عن
عمالقه الاعلام هذا الاجتماع الذي امتنع
الاذاعه عن ادراجه في الجدول المعلن عن
اعمال الرئيس الذي ينشر للعامه بالعاده
حفاظا على الشفافيه
[موسيقى]
لكن يجب الاشاره الى ان الرساله الاخباريه
من صحيفه
ولم يكن مسموحا بنشرها عنه وذلك في اليوم
التالي للغداء السري ولكن لم يلحظها احد
السر الذي صمد اربعه ايام فجرته قناه عبر
الاعلاميه التي كشفت ان الرئيس الفرنسي
اجتمع باهم الصحفيين في باريس لنقل وجهه
نظره للاعلام من دون الكشف انه اجتمع معهم
وانهم مصدر المعلومه التي نشرت في كبرى
المؤسسات الاعلاميه الفرنسيه
قسم الاتصال في الاليزين الضمان لقاء
صغيرا هو الذي يملك سره ضمه غداء للرئيس
مع عشره كتاب صحفيين تم استدعائهم فقط قبل
اربع وعشرين ساعه فقط هدف هو ايصال رساله
الرئيس ماكرون بنفسه
كيف طوليغاسيون اليساريا نشرت تقريرا حول
الموضوع لشرح حيثياته بعنوان ماذا نعرف عن
الغداء السري او غير الرسمي الذي جمع اهم
الصحفيين مع الرئيس ماكرون والذي اثار
جدلا واسعا في الاوساط الصحفيه والسياسيه
اعلام السلطه وغيرها من التعبير استخدمها
البعض ضد الاعلاميين الذين اجتمعوا
بماكرون لكن البعض راى في ذلك شعبويه
ومبالغ بها لانه من عاد بل ربما من واجب
الصحفيين الاجتماع مع مسؤولين من دون
الافصاع عن ذلك كمصدر لمعلوماتهم المتابع
اذا انا اريد ان اقول ان هذا جدال الذي لا
طائل منه والغبي يجعلني اعتقد انه من ضمن
زملائنا الصحفيين واعني البعض منهم
بالتاكيد انتصرت الشعبويه بدات الشعباويه
سياسيه وها نحن الان نرى الشعباويه
الصحفيه هناك صحفيون يتحدثون عن صحافه
الحكومه انا مقتنعه مثل الكثير من
الصحفيين وهذه هي مهنتنا انه من الاساسي
التوجه مباشره وراسا الى مصدر المعلومه
والتحدث اليه والى صناع القرار في الحياه
السياسيه والنقابيه والاجتماعيه والمنوعات
والالتقاء بالقضاه مثلا يمكنهم تناول
الغذاء معهم ايضا لا اعرف انا اين العيب
في ذلك
الموضوع لا بد من مناقشته مع مراسلنا في
باريس حسين قنيبر الذي سبق ودعي للقاء
الرئيس الفرنسي في قصر الاليزي اهلا بك
حسين هل يمكن اعتبارك من اعلام السلطه
استاذ حسين ولماذا هذه الضجه الان
بالتاكيد لا جيلان الذين يدعون الى جلسات
خاصه مع الرئيس او مع الوزير او الذين
يدعون الى ما يسمى هنا جلسه اوف ذا ريكورد
بمعنى ان الداعي يمكن ان يكون مستشارا
رئاسيا او ان يكون الرئيس نفسه او ان يكون
مستشارا للوزير او الوزير نفسه هؤلاء
يدعون الى هذه المناسبات اما لانهم يغطون
بانتظام اخبار القصر الرئاسي او اخبار
وزاره الخارجيه وهذا يكون النوع من
المكافاه لهم على جهدهم الذي قاموا به على
مدى سنوات هذا لا يعني على الاطلاق ان
الصحه في الذي يدعى هو من صحفي السلطه هذا
المفهوم ليس موجودا في فرنسا ولكن الضجه
اثيرت بعد دعوه لعدد من الصحفيين في
السابع عشر من الشهر الماضي اثيرت لثلاثه
اسباب اولا لان توقيت دعوته للصحفيين كان
حساسا جدا قبل يومين على ما سمي بالخميس
الاسود والذي كان يوم احتجاجات شعبيه
واسعه على رفع سن التقاعد او على نيه
الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما ثانيا
اثيرت الضجه لان الصحفيين طلب منهم الا
يقولوا ان المتحدث معهم الشخص الذي يعطيهم
المعلومات حول راي الحكومه في رفع سن
التقاعد الا يقولوا انه الرئيس شخصيا بل
ان يقولوا انه مصدر رفيع المستوى والسبب
الثالث للضجه التي اثيرت كان ان صحفيين
معروفين بانتقادهم للحكومه على خلفيه
تنيتها رفع سن التقاعد استبعدوا من هذه
الدعوه دعيت مثلا صحيفه لوشيغاروس صحيفه
الاعلام اخرى من بينها
وايضا مجموعه قنوات فرنسيه تابعه
لكن المعارضين لذلك يقولون ان مكروه لماذا
لم يعلن عن هذا اللقاء بشكل علني ولم يدرج
ذلك في جدول اعماله المعلنه بالعاده هذا
الماخذ على هذا اللقاء السري الذي جمع
بينه وبين الصحفيين من دون اعلام احد
الاعلام الرئاسي يقول ان من حق الرئيس ان
يدعوا الصحفيين بهذه الصوره انا اتذكر
اننا دعينا في التاسع والعشرين من كانون
الثاني يناير من العام 2021 كنا احد عشر
صحفيا من الاعلام الاجنبي صحفيين ليسوا لا
يمثلون وسائل اعلام فرنسيه كنت انا عن
قناه من الشرق الاوسط وكان هناك صحفيون
يمثلون واشنطن بوست
ريد جورنال والجار
وايضا صحفيان المانيان وممثل عن صحيفه
لاري بيبليكا الايطاليه كنا 11 شخصا سال
كل صحفيا عن منطقته واتذكر يومها انه طلب
منا عدم القول اننا دعينا الى جلسه خاصه
مع الرئيس ولكن سمح لنا بعدها ان نقول ان
الرئيس شخصيا هو من تحدث لنا هذا هو اللغط
الذي يتحدثون عنه طلب منا هذا
النقطه التي يتحدثون عنها في الاعلام
الفرنسيه انهم لم يقول المصدر ان المصدر
هو الرئيس نفسه وليس المصادر من الاليزيه
كما يعلم بالعاده نعم هذا حق للرئيس يقول
الاعلام الرئاسي الجلسه اما ان تكون
بالكامل بمعنى انه يمكننا ان نقول من هو
المصدر اسم المصدر او افضل ريكورد يمكننا
ان نعطي المعلومات التي غالبا ما تكون
معلومات مهمه لكن لا يحق لنا اذا كانت
الجلسه افضل ريكورد ان نعطي اسم الشخص
الذي تحدث لنا من هنا اثير الجدل لان
الجلسه كانت جلسه
ولكن الاعلام الرئاسي يقول ان من حق
الرئيس ان يدعو من يشاء الى القصر الرئاسي
وان يطلب منهم الا يقولوا انه هو الشخص
الذي يتحدث هذا من حق الرئيس
الافعى عن نفسه بان الرئاسه تدعو عددا
كبيرا من الصحفيين بشكل منتظم لكن من حقها
ان تخ صحفيين معينين ووسائل اعلام معينه
لمناقشه موضوعات معينه جيلان نعم بعض
النواب من اليسار طبعا طالبوا بلجنه تحقيق
عن الموضوع هل يمكن ان تتطور الامور الى
هذا الحد لا يعتقد ان تحقيق ان سيفتح بهذا
الشان هناك نواب تحديدا نائب من حركه
فرنسا العصيه من اقصى اليسار طلب باجراء
تحقيق لمعرفه ما هو المقابل الذي طلب من
هؤلاء الصحفيين مقابل دعوتهم الى القصر
الرئاسي لحضور هذه الجلسه التي كانت
السريه طبعا الصحفيون لم يطلب منهم شيء في
المقابل لم تطلب منهم تبعيه للقصر الرئاسي
كما يقولون هم على الاقل
[موسيقى]
والى موضوع اعلى من امريكا وكاله
الامريكيه في مرمى الانتقادات الاتهامات
تشير الى وقوعها في فخل صياع الاعمى
لاجنده ليبراليين المتطرفه او ما بات يعرف
بصحوه اليسار الوك التي تعيد تعريف كل شيء
بدعوى عدم جرح اي احد الوكاله نشرت اسلوب
كتابتها الجديد الذي تريد اعتماده والذي
تسعى من خلاله الى الابتعاد عن اسلوب
التعميم الذي يجرد من الانسانيه على حد
تعبيرها استشهد بريس قالت حرفيا انها تريد
ازاله داء او ال التعريف للابتعاد عن جمع
الافراد بسله واحده للدلاله عليهم كمثلا
الفقراء او المرضى نفسيا او الفرنسيين او
المعوقين
نعم حرفيا هذا ما صدر عن وكاله السوشيت
بريست تصريح غريب من الوكاله اثار ردود
فعل كثيره وسخريه عارمه ومن بين هؤلاء
السفاره الفرنسيه في واشنطن التي سرعان
معلقت عبر حسابها على تويتر السفاره اجرت
تعديلا في تسميه صفحتها الرسميه من
السفاره الفرنسيه في الولايات المتحده
لسفاره الفرنسيين كنوع من التعبير عن
سخطها بطريقه ساخره ربما
ومع تعاظم ردود الفعل حول الموضوع سحبت
الوكاله التغريده واعتذرت من الفرنسيين
وقالت انها لم تسعى ابدا الى اهانه
الفرنسيين واوضحت انها فقط ارادت مكافحه
اسلوب التعميم الذي يسلب الانسانيه من
الافراد الملياردير الامريكي ايلون ماسك
الذي ضاق ذرعا بالاعلام اليساريه دخل على
خط الجدل ورد على الوكاله بالقول فيما
انتم تطالبون بحسب تعريف عن المسميات
لماذا تسمون انفسكم
طبعا ماسك يغمز من قناه الازدواجيه في
المعايير التغطيات التي يتهم الاعلام
الليبرالي بها التغريده لقد صدى واسع خاصه
لدى المحافظين
طبعا المحافظون راوا في ذلك فرصه لتصويب
سهامهم على ما يسمى بثقافه الصحوه
الليبراليه التي تفرض امورا غريبه على
الاعلام وتهدد بالغاء كل من يعارضها وقت
نيوز ردد بانها لن تنجر الى هذا النمط من
التعبير والى هذه المزايدات الغريبه
لمراعاه شعور الناس ولكنها غير واقعيه
الكتيب عن اسلوب الكتابه الذي تتبعه بعض
الوسائل الاعلاميه لا يخصنا في فوكس ليس
بالضروره الالتزام به لذلك اسلوب كتابه
للوكاله يريد التسلل الى شاشتنا فيقومون
بامور تافهه لشد انتباهنا لا نريد اسلوب
كتابه خاصا بنا
خطا الوكاله اعاد فتح الجدال حول ثقافه
الوك المؤثره في اجنده الاعلام الامريكي
تلك الثقافه التي يرى البعض انها تفرض
مفاهيم لبراليه وتلغي كل ما هو غير ذلك
هذه الظاهره وفق البعض عززت الانقسام في
البلاد حيث بات الاعلام الرئيسيين
الامريكي نخبوي فيما لجات العامه الى
الاعلام المحافظ الذي يحاكي لغتهم
وتطلعاتهم من دون تعقيدات لغويه لا طائله
منها
[موسيقى]
التي تحاول تغيير جلدها مع رئيسها الجديد
تستعين بالمقدم الكوميديه لتقديم فقره
فكاهيه على المحطه الاخباريه هذا ما اكده
رئيس السي ان انكريست لاخذ الذي اعلن انه
سيدخ بعض الكوميديا في عروق الشبكه
الاخباريه هذا واعلن القناه انها ستبث
مقاطع للمقدم بالمار خلال برنامج سي ان
انتونايت
د
[موسيقى]
والان الى فقره اخبار الاعلام السريعه
تواجه البي بي سي نزيفا متواصلا على مستوى
نجومها مع مغادره كينجروس المحطه اسوه
بزملاء سابق له غادروا الى قنوات منافسه
فما تجميد رسوم الترخيص لم تعد باستطاعه
المحطه اغراء اسماء النجوم بالمال من اجل
البقاء وكانت اذاعه البي بي سي نيوز عربي
قد اوقفت بثها على الاثير وتحول بعض
برامجها الى المنصات الرقميه وذلك في اطار
خطه لاعاده الهيكله والتوجه الى المنصات
الرقميه
لنشر اخبارها وتطلق حسابا رسميا على
المنصه كخطوه للتكيف مع المتغيرات وفق
المعنيين بالصحيفه التي اتخذت خطوات كثيره
مؤخرات مؤخرا لترشيد انفاقها والى هنا
انتهت الحلقه اليوم موعدنا لا يتجدد
الاسبوع المقبل شكرا جزيلا للمتابعه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]